Lee is in Florida hi Lee how are you hi
Dave thank you for taking my call Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas shotgun I help
well he's been teaching my son your
program since he was about nine he
recently joined the Navy he already had
baby step three taken care of before
going to boot camp and during boot camp
he immediately started with 15 percent
as Roth TSP and had saved up enough for
a three thousand dollar short car
thinking fun and you doing really really
well but that freedom happened as soon
as he got out of boot camp he's been
spending like Congress on random
purchases like video games he's blown
through with car cons now part of
another sinking fund how do we get my
child to understand he's spending his
future because he's not slowing down
it's one of the most difficult stages of
parenting when your children become
adults because sadly stupid is not
illegal and and you really you know and
using your mom voice on a young man who
just completed boot camp after he's been
listening to a drill sergeant he that he
can't even hear you he can't even hear
you so he was taught all of this at home
correct correct through it well through
your programs we started with the FCU
Junior and then the homeschool
curriculum and then when we facilitated
FPU at our local military Chapel he was
always with us and so you guys are in
the military you're in the military job
his dad was or is dad is a chief yes
okay I would uh ideal are you anywhere
near him geographically same state
different bases he's about perfect I
think six hours away perfect during the
holidays the chief needs to sit down
with the newly graduated boot camp kid
and discuss with him not father to son
but chief in the military
- stupid young military guy and put his
arm around him and say don't be stupid
mm-hmm because we work with military all
over the world and I'll tell you this
every just about every base when you
leave the base on each side of the road
for the next two miles is every stupid
human trick can be done mm-hmm I mean
money and otherwise it's like it's like
dumb dumb dumb dumb stupid stupid stupid
all way down the road I mean so you come
out the base it's like a like a carnival
of stupidity and and these young guys
are down there it's their first paycheck
and they're and they're feeling pretty
jacked up because they've just come
through and their bodies are in better
shape than they've ever been and they
feel bulletproof and they walk out and
they just go right down the stupid
gauntlet and so you really have to
prepare but I got to tell you I do not
it be an unusual young man that's gonna
listen to his mommy
in this scenario but I bet the chief I
bet the chief could put the little bear
head in the headlock and get his
attention
okay am I wrong I don't know he's such a
spender I'm just I'm talking about how
to get through his thick little head
okay and it says it's the chief heat
listen you know why he's in the military
because his dad's his hero right okay I
hope well I mean if he hated his dad he
likely wouldn't have gone to the
military you're right I'm guessing he
admires his father which is a wonderful
thing not many people have that in this
world today good dads are very very
valuable and so dad can walk down and
have not a dad son discussion but say
listen as chief I've watched a bunch of
you little burr heads come out of boot
camp and just completely destroy the
next five years of your life because you
act like you're in Congress and you're
spending and he does not need to quote
you one time leave you out of the
conversation I'm sorry but you don't
have much power anymore in this
conversation I hope I didn't hurt your
feelings but I'm just trying to I'm
trying to think like a
a bullheaded stubborn as I was one long
time ago but I was one you know and so
I'm trying to think who can get through
to that guy because he's got
testosterone pumping right now coming
out of boot camp like never before in
his life he's square shoulder strutting
around you know you hear me I do I do
yeah and and mom voice ain't gonna cut
through that I don't think I might be
wrong I'm just thinking like a guy here
it's not working I've tried several
times as an accountability partner to
talk to him and he just he says okay mom
okay mom but then the next thing I know
he's spinning again I'm on a bank
account for money with 17 patients Endon
yeah and he's not listening yeah so
during the holidays chief just has a cup
of coffee with him in person and says
I've seen this all my life in the
military don't be one of the stupid ones
you know better we taught you at home
don't be one of the stupid ones now be a
man and man make mentally manly
decisions and that's the ability to
delay pleasure for a greater good and
it's soldiering that's what you're doing
in and saving that's what you're doing
you're delaying pleasure for a greater
good it is a it is an indication of
emotional maturity manhood is not how
square your shoulders are boy okay and
so he can welcome through that I got a
feeling Chiefs got those same kind of
words inside of him I can tell by the
way this whole family structure has gone
down that's what I'm looking at proud of
you guys tell chief thanks for a service
tell your son thanks for a service we
love both of them